welcome to the new NHL season it should be
[Applause] electric Chris Lee out there along
with Wes mccaulay our referees tonight and
it is certainly electric what an atmosphere
here at T-Mobile Arena the starting lineups
brought to you by Taco Bell across the top
of your screen an early icing call will
bring the face off back down into the
vgk got to think about the nerves for both
of these teams and you mentioned it briefly
earlier and we talked to Bruce Cassidy about it
too how did the Vegas golden knights respond to
all of this emotion the last couple days the
Rings the bannner everything they have going
on and the Vegas golden knights still without
a shot on net part of that of course the fact
that they had to kill 2 minutes of power play
time and a take away by bers behind the net
bers finds a cutter lson AER that just goes wide
marshas up tracks it down saucers a pass nicely
trapped out of midair by barbashev but he is
all by as Lonesome surrounded by three and now
four members of the Kraken and bers takes the puck
away rakovski snaps one ahead to Vin done a drop
pass shot on there oh great right P save made by
Aiden Hill as he stoned bovin and what a clear by
Alex petrangelo very quickly gets that puck out
of Harm's Way spoken like a true defenseman you
appreciate that as Chandler Stevenson brings it
across out back door SC the first shot off that
ends up behind broow Tick Tac Toe the bgk strike
first Chandler Stevenson on the board is key to
then start the transition up Chandler Stevenson
comes through the neutral zone with speed and as
you mentioned Tick Tac Toe that is how you T it up
for all the youth hockey coaches out there that's
what you want to show your players that's how you
do it quick passes a quick touch Beautiful Finish
there by Chandler Stevenson to win the Stanley Cup
that certainly puts them in Elite company quickest
on that list of Champions to win out in the front
shot on that safe made the rebound swept just wide
by barbashev one of those assistant Captain A's
by Bruce Cassidy Paul cter sends it in there is
Carlson behind the net sweeps one out front good
job by T who puts it in his own neck T tried to
carry it behind the cage PL it towards the net
and it carams in two nothing Vegas it looks like
he'll get the goal yeah this is a this is a just
a broken play they get the puck in deep and then
they go to work and this is really the calling
card of the Vegas golden KN tough Pursuit they
go in and then it's just a really really bad
bounce for Seattle here here canev is trying
to put the puck behind the net marsho timely poke
of his sick and it ends up behind grow and minor
changes at best adding a dumlin a Yamamoto deer
eduward Balmar for Seattle but for the most part
the Kracken trying to run it back as there's a
takeway by Carlson another unfortunate bounce for
Seattle and Carlson had a point flank look he ends
up with the puck in the left wing Corner C her out
front oh that save made by gr bow oh he robed to
Mania terrific save by Philip grow we are right
now under two minutes the Vegas golden knights
are buzzing with this TW goal lead with this
electric atmosphere and look at them they're just
having their way with the puff right now they're
playing keep away and look at where amadio is
that's one thing that Bruce Cassidy wanted him to
change Seattle had the first five shots of
the game and actually outshot attempted the
Vegas golden kns in the opening period 30- 17 on
block shots usually a factor as the Vegas golden
knights blocked nine and of course last year they
had three of the top seven players on the block
shot leaderboard in the National Hockey League
we mentioned tonight that they are playing as
that puck is on the doorstep and it ends up behind
grow plays one past bers it stops Everly carries
download to bers off the heel of his step ends up
with Dunn he'll wind it deep mcav skates onto it
for the golden knights oh beautiful Outlet pass
the barf who moves in Hook from behind SC what a
pass what a finish 3 nothing Vegas what a play
here incredible pass from Braden McNab up to a
breaking Ivan barbashev you can see bar takes a
little shoulder check over his right shoulder to
see who's coming behind him who the defender
is and he uses his body to make sure that he
puts his body between his left shot right here
he gets that body there so that VIN dun cannot
lift his stick Larson ahead hoping for fmar it
ends up in the corner AAL is there his stick
is lifted Yanni gour on and a save made with the
blocker by Aiden Hill and that allows a clear by
Ben Hutton Gord rink wide holding and across high
slot wrist shot that caught some iron that's snuck
behind Hill ell tolin and that close to getting
Seattle on the board yti Gord the first to it in
the left wing corner Corner G carries it out to
the red line Alexia walks it down alexc centering
pass oh just put wide by Will borgan with the
puck on both teams and it's pretty wide open
chances at both ends of the ice good looks by
Seattle Aiden Hill so far up to the challenge
but they are putting pressure on despite almost
the D to D back door goal and borgan missed he
couldn't finish barbashev finished a moment ago
tow drag between the legs on net covered by GR
power go some shuffling of course without White
Cloud as well back to the point Duman rank wide
one time Drive fought off Justin Schulz put it
off the left pad of Aiden Hill in the corner
it's thrown out in front that shot score Jared
mccan the 40 goal scorer from last season on the
board on opening night as are the Kraken as they
try and fight their way back in it they win the
face off too by the way they keep the puck in the
offensive zone and then they're able to jump on
the puck look the way Matty veneers is in there
he's battling he's winning that battle and it's
right there the that pass was intended across
the slot it was trying to go and it deflected
right off of Maro and you could see that the puck
was trying to go to Justin Schultz the D had snuck
in we've talked a little bit about how Seattle's
trying to activate this is their first opportunity
Maro walks it in wrist shot save the rebound on
that Stone Point Blank had a chance and gr bow
was there right off the face off a good faceof win
here clean win and then come in for Maro and then
it's Mark Stone he's got that big long stick he
does an excellent job in net front watch him he
comes across he's on his forehand all he has to
do is lower that during the playoffs he went on a
tear in the last 15 games scored 13 goals seven
over half of them seven of them were assisted
by Jack eel and then together with barbashev the
chemistry on that line was undeniable yeah there
was some concern during the opening round that
their goal scorers weren't scoring goals and
certainly marsho was on that list as a glove save
is made here by guau to open up the third off the
Stick of nicku is no small figure at 6'4 moving in
bers R shot save made by Hill kicked it out with
the left P Rob bers Anders has a centering pass
that floats in on hill and he covers up as Everly
thought he might be able to tuck it behind for
this them and this is an old school save too he
kicks out his left left leg to get that rebound
out you know it's interesting as you mentioned
he's big he's 6'4 he moves really well and one
thing he's adjusted with the new goalie coach here
in empty net for Seattle verovski hit by Chandler
Stevenson EO for the empty net [Applause] [Music]
SCS their heroes from the playoffs ice this
one and you know what's impressive here is
watch the play against the the boards over
there Chandler Stevenson and then it's a pass
up and Jack Mel but otherwise they had some
chances the crowd at The Fortress celebrates
a banner raising and the Stanley Cup to start
and they celebrate a 4-1 win on opening night